you have one singer left mighty one yes
okay how confident are you that you can
beat the boys this season I'm confident
I'm I'm confident I think that people
really connect with her people love her
she's so good she's so dang good she's
like I feel like a whole package as an
artist
um so I'm pretty damn confident pretty
dang confident now you shared the
sweetest little moment with Gwen Stefani
right there if worst case scenario your
singer does go home which other coach
would you be pulling to take home the
win would it be Gwen well I think for me
um it's more about like artists so uh I
don't know I'm I'm a fan of everybody
else but um
I love Morgan I love Bodie like I
I love I love everybody but I am a fan
of like what Bodhi does too
at this point I feel like getting this
far everyone is essentially a winner too
oh my god of course are you kidding like
imagine how many people auditioned like
millions of people audition so to be
like in the top eight it's like you
clearly
you're doing something right exactly
when you open your mouth and sing
exactly now what would be a major win
would be a collaboration between you and
Gwen Stefani what do we have to do to
make
to make I mean we're so much closer than
we've ever been by being on The Voice
together so
that's the start it's a big start she
literally called you her daughter I mean
come on mother-daughter Duo right here
yeah I mean I love her I love her she's
the best what would be the vibe of that
type of collaboration if it were to
happen be like very like
like fu
girl power you know what I mean because
I feel like that's she's so that like
she just is such a punk rocker at heart
and I I feel like she's
just trailblazed for so many
women that feel like like I don't know
she's just like a weirdo and like the
best way and those are my favorite kind
of artists and those are my favorite
kind of like female artists too so I
love that of course women supporting
women so important especially in this
industry it's so sweet and of course the
holidays Camila are coming up right
around the corner what are the plans yes
um I just want to like bake okay and uh
like binge things like binge TV shows
uh spend time with my dogs but mostly
baking comes to mind okay what are we
baking in the kitchen lots of cookies
lots of cookies
Camilla's cookies I like it
now of course speaking with the holidays
what is the most memorable gift that you
have ever gotten
I the only like the always what comes to
mind is I got Santa gave me
a uh a bell from Have You Ever Seen The
Polar Express when you you when the guy
got
um the main character gets the Bell from
the sleigh I don't know if you remember
but I also got one from Santa Claus a
bell from the sleigh and only if you
believe in Santa can you hear it and I
heard it where do you keep that
awesome you got no I don't know where it
is but it was it's okay it was special
at the time well I feel like a good
present a good holiday present for you
this year would be a win here at the
voice right yes yes
[Music]